hi this is conan o'brien and this is my
video response to michelle fans
spoon beauty tip video
uh i like to caution people out there
not to try michelle's beauty tip with
spoons it doesn't work i took this spoon
and i put it in the freezer and i left
it there for a couple of hours and then
just like michelle said i placed it over
my right eye
and
what happened is it stuck to the eye it
actually
the steel the cold steel adhered to the
ocular jelly
in my right eye
i was screaming in pain
i was medevaced uh to a hospital that
specializes in ocular surgery
it was a 14 hour operation to remove the
frozen spoon
from my eye i lost sight in my eye
for about
four months i had no depth perception
during that time
i subsequently went back to the hospital
and had reconstructive surgery done on
the eye area because eventually they
just had to tear the spoon off it tore
skin
total cost to me was in the neighborhood
of 245 000. uh that's not even including
the helicopter that medevac me too the
ocular surgeon which was another 75 000
because they also they took the long way
around frankly i believe i think there
was a shorter way to get there anyway
uh all respect to michelle phan and her
beauty tips but don't put a frozen spoon
up to your ocular jelly
it's a mistake
and uh
please subscribe to my channel